In each lesson, you'll build a specific piece of the festival
lab. So that you can understand the use case, Samantha and
Andy are going to take you to an actual music festival, so
that you can really understand the problem you're solving in that lesson.
>> As Andy and I guide you through building the app, I'll
be teaching you and him how to actually build the app itself.
>> And since I truly don't know anything about
Salesforce I'll be playing the role of the student. Sam?
>>
[LAUGH]
Yes.
>> You are teaching me how to build the app.
>> Right.
>> And I'm building the app.
>> Yep.
>> And, Mario?
>> Interrupting you.
>> You're, thanks, Mario.
>> And I'll be interrupting the class every so often to give context about
what we're learning as well as to
explain some of the more difficult concepts. While
also asking you a lot of the questions like what was the first concert
you went to? Answering these questions is
really going to help to facilitate your learning.
>> So what was the first concert
that you went to, Mario?
>> Boston.
>> Green Day.
>> Blink 182. What about you?